♪ ♪
>> Greg: WE ARE 76 DAYS INTO
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
SO HE'S ALMOST DONE.
[LAUGHTER]
YUP, HE'S ALREADY 70 DAYS LONGER
THAN WE EXPECTED.
LOTS OF BITE AND POLICIES TO
REPORT ON, YET JOURNALISTS CAN'T
STOP TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW WHO.
SPEAK I'D LOVE TO HEAR FROM BOTH
OF YOU HOW D.C. JOURNALISTS ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE BIDEN ERA.
THIS IS YOUR FIRST WEEKEND
AIRING HERE, DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOUR LINEUP IS REALLY DIFFERENT
THAN WOULD'VE BEEN BEEN IN THE
TRUMP YEARS?
>> WHEN YOU ARE ASKING ME IF I
WAS AROUND OUTCOME I THOUGHT YOU
WERE REFERRING TO HOW I FELT
DURING THE TRUMP ERA.
NOW, I THINK THAT -- LISTEN, WE
ARE ALL DEALING WITH SOME POST
TRUMP STRESS DISORDER.
OTHER THAN THAT HAPPY EASTER AS
HE WAS SAYING IN THE STATEMENTS
A FEW DAYS AGO.
>> Greg: THE OUTCOME OF THESE
CHUCKLE BUCKETS ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME DRYING OUT FROM THE
TRUMP ERA.
EVEN IF THEY CAN CALL IT A DAY
AT 4:30 IN THE AFTERNOON WHILE
PRESIDENT BIDEN DIGESTS HIS
EARLY BIRD TAPIOCA.
AND ONE NETWORK IS CORNERING THE
MARKET.
>> YOU ARE WATCHING ATN, ALL
TRUMP AND HIS BECAUSE EVERYTHING
ELSE IS BORING BY COMPARISON.
>> THE ANNUAL GLOBAL RETIREMENT
INDEXES OUT WITH ITS LATEST LIST
OF THE BEST PLACES IN THE WORLD
TO SPEND YOUR GOLDEN YEARS.
TOPPING THE LIST THIS YEAR,
COSTA RICA FOLLOWED BY PANAMA
AND MEXICO.
SOURCES SAY IF TRUMP WAS ELECTED
IN 2024, WE CAN EXPECT ALL
AMERICANS TO RETIRE AND MOVE TO
LITERALLY ANY COUNTRY WHERE
TRUMP IS NOT PRESIDENT.
I WILL BE ON THE FIRST PLANE TO
BERMUDA WITH A SUITCASE FULL OF
EGG ROLLS.
WEEKEND TRAFFIC JAM NEAR
ATLANTA.
POSSIBLY SPOOKED BY A PHONE CALL
FROM DONALD TRUMP.
CARS WERE AT A STANDSTILL FOR
ABOUT AN HOUR UNTIL POLICE WERE
ABLE TO SAFELY CAPTURE THE COW
AND RETURN IT TO ITS OWNER.
SOURCES SAY THIS NEVER WOULD'VE
HAPPENED IF DONALD TRUMP HAD AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN THAT
CONSISTED OF MORE THAN JUST
TURNING WAYWARD CAPITALS INTO
WELL DONE STEAK.
I SWEAR, I DO NOT KNOW HOW WE
EVER SURVIVE THAT GUY.
A NEW STUDY SHOWS THAT PEOPLE
CANNOT TELL THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SCREAMS OF JOY AND
SCREAMS OF TERROR.
RESEARCHERS AT THE UNIVERSITY
SAY TWO TYPES OF SCREAMS HAVE
SIMILAR ACOUSTICS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF I ATTENDED A
SUGAR RAY CONCERT AND THE 90s,
SHEER JOY.
[SCREAMS]
BUT IF I WAS AT A TRUMP RALLY,
UNMITIGATED TERROR.
[SCREAMS]
ALL OF THE PEOPLE WITH THE
CHILDREN AND THE GRANDPARENTS
AND THE YMCA.
MAKES ME SICK TO MY STOMACH.
SERIOUSLY.
ALTHOUGH, HE VOTED FOR JUMP
TWICE.
GOD, I HATE HIM.
MORE HEADLINES IN 30 MINUTES, I
AM ANDERSON LONDON.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I AM WORRIED ABOUT
HER.
ERIC, WHAT IS IT LIKE TO KNOW
THAT YOUR DAD HAS A REALLY
UNUSUAL PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECT ON
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY IN THE MEDIA.
UNLESS YOU'VE EXPERIENCED IT
YOURSELF.
>> TRUST ME, I'VE EXPERIENCED IT
MYSELF.
TO SEE A COST TO ACT LIKE THAT,
IT'S REFRESHING PRETTY BUT IT'S
TRUE, CAN I CALL IT FOR WHAT IT
DOES?
BIDEN IS BORING AS HELL, KAMALA
IS NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
IF I TOOK 1 PENNY FROM CHINA, IF
I TOOK 1 PENNY FROM THE UKRAINE,
IF I WAS SMOKING PARMESAN
CHEESE -- I MEAN, HE COULDN'T
HAVE GOTTEN ELECTED.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU SAY ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO PEOPLE WHO SMOKE
PARMESAN CHEESE.
>> Greg: CAN WE LET THE TOPIC
GO QUESTION MARKS BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT HELP THEMSELVES.
IT IS ALL TRUMPED ALL THE TIME,
THEY CAN'T LET HIM GO.
REMEMBER HOW ENTERTAINING THE
PRESS CONFERENCES WERE BACK IN
THE DAY.
THEY WERE SHOUTING JIM ACOSTA
OUTCOME OF THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
MY FATHER HAS NEVER HAD A SIP OF
WINE IN HIS LIFE, HE'S NEVER
DONE DRUGS IN HIS LIFE.
THEIR RATINGS STINK NOW.
TWITTER IS BORING.
>> IT'S HARD, BECAUSE BEFORE ALL
THEY HAD TO DO WAS ROLL A TAPE
AND SIT THERE AND GO, WOW.
WOW.
THAT'S NOT HAVING PTSD NOW THAT
THAT'S OVER, THEY NOW HAVE TO
THINK.
THEY NOW NEED TO THINK A LITTLE
HARDER.
IT'S NOTHING LIKE PTSD, AND IT
CAN BE TOUGH.
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU SHUT YOUR
BRAIN OFF, YOU GO TO BONNEVILLE
FOR A COUPLE DAYS.
AND THEN YOU ARE ON THE CAR ON
THE WAY TO THE AIRPORT ON THE
WAY BACK AND YOU ARE LIKE CAN I
STILL READ?
KIND OF LIKE THAT, WHICH IS HARD
AND SCARY.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHEN YOU THINK
YOU MIGHT HAVE DONE SOME SORT OF
PERMANENT DAMAGE BECAUSE
TEMPORARILY YOU THINK IT'S OVER.
>> RIGHT, EXACTLY.
YOU CAN WORK THROUGH IT, IT IS
NOT PTSD.
YOU ARE A LITTLE RUSTY ON THE
THINKING.
>> Greg: THE THING IS, WE ARE
ALMOST GUILTY OF THE SAME THING,
BECAUSE WE ARE SITTING HERE
TALKING ABOUT IT TOO.
>> IT'S DIFFERENT.
YOU GUYS CANNOT ALL BE WRONGER.
THIS IS NOTHING TO DO WITH -- IT
IS BANK DISORDER.
IT IS LOW RATINGS.
EVERY TIME I GOT TO WRITE A BOOK
ABOUT HIM, I WAS MAKING MONEY
ABOUT HIM, I WAS GETTING
PROMOTIONS BECAUSE HE PICKED ON
ME AT A PRESS CONFERENCE.
HE WAS GOOD FOR MY BOTTOM LINE.
NOBODY'S BUYING A BOOK THAT
DIDN'T HAVE TRUMP NAMES ON IT.
I JUST WANTED TO PUT OUT ABOUT
THAT JUST SAID TRUMP, TRUMP,
TRUMP, 365 PAGES OF TRUMP.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY
HURTING.
THEIR POCKETS, BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T HAVE BOOKS ANYMORE, THEY
CAN'T GET PAID FOR ONE-ON-ONE
INTERVIEWS TO TALK ABOUT THE
TIME THAT HE TOLD HIM HE WAS
UNFAIR.
SO THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO --
THEY ARE HOPING THAT THEY WILL
SAY SOMETHING, BECAUSE IN THE
PAST IF YOU TOOK A SHOT AT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE WOULD FIRE
TO PIECE BACK AT YOU AND BOOM,
YOU HAVE A BOOK AGAIN AND YOU
ARE ON EVERYONE'S TV SHOW
BECAUSE HE GOT BREAKING NEWS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSULTED ME,
ROLL THE TAPES.
THEN YOU GET A PANEL OF 47
PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT IT AND THEN
TWO WEEKS LATER, MY BOOK, TRUMP
TERRORIZED ME."
NOBODY WANTS THE GYM ACOSTA DAY
AT WORK BOOK.
[LAUGHTER]
THINK ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: WHAT WOULD BE POPPING
UP, I DON'T KNOW?
THAT POP-UP BOOK WOULD BE REALLY
BAD.
REALLY BAD.
ENOUGH WITH THE POP-UP BOOK
JOKES, CAT.
>> WHAT?
>> I DISAGREE.
I THINK THEY DO SUFFER FROM A
PSYCHIATRIC DISORDER AT CNN.
I HAVE WONDERED WHAT IT WAS, I
THOUGHT IT WAS NARCISSISTIC
PERSONALITY DISORDER.
I'VE SEEN ALL THE SYMPTOMS, THE
DELUSIONS OF GRANDEUR, THE
RAMBLING ON ABOUT IMAGINARY
IRRELEVANT --
>> THEY TRIED TO REPLACE TRUMP
WITH JOE BIDEN'S
GERMAN SHEPHERD.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET US
INTERESTED IN THIS.
BEWITCHED AFTER THEY TOOK THE
LAST DAY OR IN A WAY.
IT'S SHOW.
AND I DON'T BLAME THEM.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS NOT TRUMP,
THE PROBLEM IS WHEN HE WENT AWAY
IT REVEALED HOW SICK IN FACT
THEY REALLY WERE.
THEY NO LONGER HAD SOMEBODY TO
BOUNCE IT OFF OF.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SAYING TRUMP
IS YORK AND BIDEN'S SARGENT.
AND HUNTER BIDEN -- YOU DIDN'T
SEE THAT ONE COMING, DID YOU?
DID YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT